rossi the grammys are this weekend i
know i'll be watching
i'm so excited because trevor noah is
hosting and i love trevor noah
and the best and we're gonna get into it
tomorrow
with um entertainment tonight's kevin
frazier he's a good friend of the show
he's almost on weekly at this point
and one of the most heated categories is
record of the
year and the field is just packed with
some of the best songs ever it is hard
you know dualipa billy eilish post
malone
beyonce the list goes on and on savage
megan lee stallion so ross and i are
starting a poll with our digital team go
to the drew barrymore show
facebook page and vote for who you think
we should who should win and tomorrow
we'll all read the results of that poll
together
yeah i was going through the list there
are so many good songs maybe it's just
that we were all like stuck at home
watching tv and listening to music but i
think i know the words to all of those
songs so we're gonna break it down
tomorrow i think it was a really good
year for songs
yeah regardless mm-hmm all right are you
going to have your pick ready rossi oh
yes i already think i have my pick but
i'll tune in tomorrow to hear it okay
perfect i'll be ready to go
too all right first up we have got some
groundbreaking news
in hollywood variety reports that apple
tv plus
has just inked a deal with malala
yousafza
apple has been partnering with everyone
from steven spielberg to oprah
and now malala she is a global champion
for human rights girls educations and i
can't wait
to see her passion and perspective on
apple to think that somebody who
was they tried to keep her quiet they
tried to kill her and now she's going to
have this platform the most epic
platform
ever what will she say now we'll all be
listening
she is incredible and i cannot wait to
tune in she is here for a reason she's
got something to say
and we'll all be there for it and we've
got some news about a healthy fast food
chain chipotle oh god that sounds good
right chipotle
there's one around the corner and you
know ross matthews had been known to pop
by
and now they have something very new
bustle reports they've teamed up with
elf cosmetics
for a chipotle new makeup line it comes
with a cute avocado applicators
called applicators no but they should be
called that
uh and then this eye shadow palette i'm
seeing there's a guac
inspired green maybe some shades of bean
in there
and check out that fiery red lip shade
it's a little spicy
a lip plopping gloss okay we love
a collaboration did you see this one
coming this uh chipotle and elf
cosmetics you have
it there right i'm obsessed i love this
oh my gosh this is a makeup bag
literally like a to-go bag yeah that's
cute this
is so fun and smart elf and chipotle
i want to eat you and wear you do you
can you it gets me excited like other
collabs you can have like i know you
love a filet-o-fish
do you think like a flower beauty could
do some sort of like tartar face mask or
something
i mean flower beauty and mcdonald's
anything
flower beauty would love to collab with
a company
it's just i'm trying on the spicy
lip plumping can you feel it it
definitely has an essence of like
spicy cinnamon i'm not mad at that i'm
tingling
well and after you chomp that chipotle
guess what
we've got the latest fitness trend that
is burning up
on tick tock gq reports that the
weighted hula hoop
is great cardio for your heart and a
great workout for your core
and that's really important the core
yeah i have strong core values but not a
strong core
i didn't meet my core until i was like
42. yeah
um and the best part is you already know
how to do it it's hula hooping it's like
riding a bike the hips always remember
and they come in a variety of weights
and today we're working out with the two
pounder
two pound now are you a a good hula
hooper in general
oh ross i think you're about to find out
yeah
[Laughter]
i'm like shakira my hips but except my
hips do lie i don't think i have the
motion
okay i this is okay ready this is how i
hula hoop
go okay oh wait that's actually the most
it's ever stayed on in my life
hold on let me hold up the whole point
is to keep it up above the oh
oh oh i can do it
i didn't know i could do this everybody
why can't i keep it up do it a little
higher i have like a nice
fat roll right here that's holding it up
do you know how hard that is i didn't
know i could do that until this very i
love that we had this together thank you
for joining
wow that by the way you guys i've never
been more of a natural than anything in
my entire life
drew i didn't even know you always
amazed me rossi
how do you think i feel oh my gosh
you